as the spring jamboree returned to
downtown boulder city today the
community really came out to support
local vendors getting back in the swing
of things after the pandemic jeremy j
ford was there and spoke to some local
vendors who say it's really great to be
back
the boulder city spring jamboree is a
festival that's sure to have something
for everyone and now in its 45th year it
continues to put an emphasis on the
success
of its vendors
so it's fun to see them get back here
jill lagan boulder chamber ceo and event
director tells me it's great to see the
vendors moving product started as a way
for them to have a place to display and
be a weekend of celebration of not only
the businesses especially in the
historic district at that time but just
for us to celebrate local businesses
like 360 me las vegas a photo booth
business owned by anastasia manis we
come out to any kind of private events
corporate events birthdays baby showers
we make a custom overlay and we can put
your picture on it as a personal memento
for anyone who employs her services
people getting together that's what
we're about and people having a good
time our whole mission is to make sure
those businesses are promoted celebrated
and have people walking through their
doors this is a fabulous way to make
that happen from boulder city jeremy j
ford live local now